[Aplausos]
[Música]
tranquilos si hablo
y quiero preguntarles quién me entendió
lo que acaba de decir ahorita
levanten la mano los que me entendieron
ok
ahora quiero que piensen por un minuto
que es lo que sintieron cuando pasé y
empecé a hablar en lengua de señas
y quiero que lo piensen por un momento
existen más de 64.000 personas sordas
registradas en el canales en el consejo
de discapacidad aquí en el ecuador
tal vez 64 mil personas no suene mucho
pero 64 mil personas equivale a llenar 6
universidades como están completas 6
católicas y un poquito más
obviamente yo tampoco sabía nada de esto
ni de la lengua de señas ni de cultura
de personas sordas hasta después que
decidí a estudiar educación especial con
un enfoque en lengua de señas para
personas sordas
muchas muchas muchas muchas personas me
preguntan por qué decidí enfocarme en
una carrera tan diferente como esta
claramente aquí en el ecuador no hay esa
carrera
y bueno es por eso que yo decidí ir a
estudiar al extranjero super feliz
emocionada de vivir una nueva
experiencia conocer nueva gente
así es que en el 2010
y tomó un vuelo y me voy a eeuu
cuando llegué eeuu me estaba esperando
mi familia anfitriona o mi host family
como se conoce aquí les presento me
gustan y cuando los veo
saludo a mamá a papá a los tres chicos
de atrás que son mis hermanos ya mi
hermana muy feliz me acerco les saludo y
todos me abrazan ya se imaginará fue muy
emotivo pero en eso a mí se me acerca y
me dice hola damaris cómo estás mi
nombre es alí y yo soy tu nueva hermana
pero fue más de la siguiente manera
correcto mi hermana era sorda o es sorda
no
cuando vi eso también tuve la misma cara
que ustedes hicieron cuando empecé a
hablar en lengua de señas mi cara y mi
reacción fue diferente fue rara de todas
maneras empezamos a conversar en lo que
se podía y en la cena me empezaron a
explicar que si de hecho y en efecto ali
es una persona sorda
al es una persona que utiliza lengua de
señas y que bueno es la forma de
comunicarse entre ellos mamá papá y
hermanos todos son oyentes como nosotros
pero también dominan la lengua de señas
entonces veo ahí a todo el mundo
hablando en lengua de señas y en este
momento y yo me sentí la persona más
excluida en el mundo
y en ese momento dije no tengo que
aprender lengua de señas y lo voy a
hacer y porque me motivó muchísimo a
aprender primero porque todos sabían
lengua de señas y luego porque hasta el
perro entendía la lengua de señas
es por eso que bueno empieza a estudiar
al y se convirtió en mi mejor amiga y mi
hermana mayor
ali fue la persona que me enseñó a
manejar me enseñó a manejar moto me hizo
altura en la universidad me llevaban los
restaurantes aquí ya conozca me llevaba
a abrir mi cuenta en el banco ya se
imaginan todo el sello cultural que yo
tenía y toda esa experiencia la viví con
alguien
al convivir con ella aprendí muchísimo
no aprendí mucho de las personas sordas
aprendí de la comunidad aprendí de su
cultura aprendí de cómo ellos viven y de
la lengua de señas
algo que impacto mucho en mi vida fue
que como aquí en muchos países no todos
saben lengua de señas por lo que ya
ocupaba el servicio del intérprete de
lengua de señas que es una persona que
cumple el rol de ser el intérprete entre
la persona sorda y la persona oyente que
se quiere comunicar
el intérprete de lengua de señas me
impactó tanto generó un gran impacto en
mi vida a conocer a alguien así que yo
decidí estudiar para ser un intérprete
de lengua de señas entonces
por tal motivo estudie educación
especial con un enfoque en lengua de
señas
pasaron los años después de los cinco
años me gradué una hermosa experiencia
pero no todo acaba ahí
el gran reto empieza cuando yo regrese a
ecuador
y yo regreso muy feliz con todo lo que
aprendí quería compartir mi hermosa
experiencia que yo viví y quería hacer
ese puente de comunicación para las
personas sordas y brindar un gran apoyo
para todos ellos
y bueno que creen que pasa cuando viene
ecuador
o sea está
mi cabeza no existe todavía y ha pasado
cinco años
entonces dije no saben que ok no no lo
hay aquí en el ecuador está muy difícil
está difícil hacer algo relacionado para
apoyar a la comunidad sorda no hay
problema a los 22 años decidí a empezar
mi propia fundación
fundación salud o un nuevo comienzo y
cuál es el enfoque de nuestra fundación
con la fundación queríamos llegar a más
personas a más docentes a más
capacitadores que puedan conocer sobre
la inclusión sobre lo que es una persona
sorda sobre la lengua de señas y
estábamos llegando hacíamos viajes
capacitamos a profesores
después de todo el trabajo que se estaba
haciendo yo sentía que algo hacía falta
todavía sentía que a pesar que estamos
ayudando a una gran comunidad a personas
con discapacidad auditiva sentía que el
resto de las personas como nosotros
teníamos que conocer quería que ustedes
conozcan el mundo del que yo me enamoré
el mundo que me encantó y el mundo con
el cual trabajo
así es cómo
en mi proyecto y en mi cabeza se me
ocurre a ser un lugar inclusivo les
pregunto qué pasaría si ustedes saliendo
de aquí van y visitan un lugar donde
todas las personas que les atienden son
sordas
donde ustedes agregar y sentarse y
quieren pedir un café lo tienen que
hacer en lengua de señas y no saben cómo
hacerlo
quiero que piensen cómo se sentiría en
verdad precisamente eso fue lo que quise
crear
cuando empecé con este lindo proyecto
llamado caffeine seca
y qué hacemos encaja en señas es una
cafetería inclusiva donde personas
sordas trabajas donde ellos te atienden
donde tú vas y pides un café y te lo dan
pero tú eres la persona que tiene que
adaptarse a su mundo
qué hacemos en café enseñas bueno aparte
de ser una cafetería nosotros celebramos
cumpleaños
nosotros hacemos eventos en diferentes
actividades
nosotros hacemos karaoke en lengua de
señas sí amigos las personas sordas
pueden cantar
sí y formalizó una de las experiencias
más lindas que me llevo
algo que me impactó muchísimo al momento
de crear café en señas al momento de la
contratación
publicamos en redes sociales nos
reunimos con varias personas sordas a
las que entrevistamos y bueno le
pregunto a patti una de las chicas que
trabaja con nosotros le digo cómo te
enteraste de de la publicación que
hicimos me dijo bueno entre amigos nos
pasamos la voz no exactamente la voz
pero entre amigos se comunicaron
y lo que me dijo fue para ti
muchísimas gracias por esta gran
oportunidad
esta es la primera vez que mi
discapacidad es un requerimiento para
algo
imagínense el gran impacto que yo sentí
cuando para ti me dijo esto empezamos
con el proyecto
tuvo una gran acogida van personas
oyentes como nosotros que no sabemos
entran a la cafetería y se llevan una
gran experiencia o por lo menos salen
aprendiendo una nueva seña
y eso es lo que queremos lograr con café
interés
lo que ustedes sintieron cuando yo me
paré aquí y empecé a hablar con las
manos es lo que las personas sordas
sienten todo el tiempo ese sentimiento
tal vez de angustia de ansiedad de
desesperación de no saber lo que va
madrid me estaba diciendo con las manos
eso es lo que ellos sienten todos los
días
y genera incluso aislamiento para ellos
e imagínense las personas sordas no
eligieron ser sordas verdad los
molinenses sordos nadie elige tener una
cierta condición
y eso me hace pensar quienes de verdad
tenemos la discapacidad entonces somos
nosotros
teniendo la capacidad de aprender de
hacer algo nuevo no lo hacemos
y bueno ahora qué
el proyecto muy lindo muy inclusivo pero
ahora qué
qué estás haciendo tú qué están haciendo
ustedes para crear un cambio positivo en
la sociedad
[Música]
tal vez con estas pequeñas acciones no
estoy cambiando el mundo
pero si cambia la vida de para ti
verdad
quiero que salgamos más allá de este
proyecto inclusivo y quiero que de
verdad pensemos un momento
en qué pasaría
si el día de mañana nos despertamos
salimos a la calle y todas las personas
empiezan a hablar en lengua de señas
y cada uno de ustedes es la persona rara
la que tiene que encajar en un mundo
tal vez así podamos educar a nuestra
mente
hay que ser diferente es normal y está
bien
y estamos enseñando a nuestros hijos a
nuestros amigos a nuestros empleados
pero de verdad pensemos por un momento
aunque legado les estamos dejando
el día de mañana cuando ya no estemos
aquí tal vez una educación en un aula de
clase es suficiente
yo creo que no
yo creo que mostrar la realidad tal cual
es vale mucho más que estar atrás de una
de un sillón o de una pizarra
aprendiendo importante pero demos ese
paso adicional
hagamos algo más salgamos de esta zona
de confort que nos sentimos cómodos que
nos gusta y arriesgué monos hacer cosas
nuevas y diferentes
de verdad espero que todos encontremos
una alí
en su vida como yo lo hice y si no le
encuentran sean esa ali en la vida de
alguien
en ese cambio
y no es difícil me van a preguntar pero
damaris yo no sé lengua de señas cómo
puedo comunicarme con una persona sorda
como hablo con la persona que está al
lado mío si me dan nervios
da ese extra paso sólo hazlo y no tienes
que saber lengua de señas para hablar
con una persona sorda
qué es lo mejor que puedes hacer ser una
persona paciente sea una persona con
menta abierta sea una persona que quiere
lograr un cambio en esta vida y los
cambios empiezan
desde nosotros
quisiera enseñarles unas señas
para que por lo menos si es que esto no
les quedó o se olvidan aprendan unas
tres señas que les quiero enseñar está
bien así que vamos a ver vamos a repetir
conmigo una de las señas que más me
gusta y creo que te puede abrir el
camino a un mundo increíble como de las
personas sordas la primera vamos a
aprender gracias y vamos a repetir
hagámoslo gracias
es cierto gracias perfecto la segunda es
por favor
y la tercera es te quiero
y bueno para las personas que se estaban
preguntando qué es lo que dije cuando
empecé a mover las manos cuando llegué
y dije lo siguiente mi superpoder es
saber lengua de señas cuál es el tuyo
y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]